un anniversaire sans gâteau c'est pas un
anniversaire
jetez un coup d'oeil à vos albums photos
pour voir quelle place le gâteau occupe
dans la fête
mais avez-vous remarqué à quel point la
décoration de gâteaux a évolué depuis
quelques années une des tendances fortes
scellé le jeune tchèque ces gâteaux
trompe-l'oeil hyper réaliste la partie
c'est la création de bonnart assez sexy
caroline lacroix a délaissé son métier
de maquilleuse coiffeuse pour se
consacrer à la création de gâteaux
extraordinaire dont se sculpter ou 3d
des gâteaux en 3d est ce qu'on serait
capable de faire ça la maison je vous
dirais c'est pas un faiseur mais il faut
surtout le 3d c'est un type ambitieux je
dirais pour démarrer parce qu'il ya
souvent une question de structure pour
que ça tienne le mieux c'est de démarrer
avec des gâteaux ronds carrés standard
puis d'ajouter des éléments de décor
dessus moi ça c'est dangereux j'ai juste
le goût de goûter le haut et fleury n'a
cessé de fondre ou pour non c'est sûr ça
c'est une maxime hautbois
une poche à douille et vous voici prêt à
faire vos premiers pas dans la
décoration de gâteaux comment faire une
belle rose est de crem en fait on mange
pas retrait du simple je donne plus de
pression je manque et après ça je réduis
l'impression que jamais leur strauss et
pour faire une rose pour commencer vous
allez vous faire un petit conte ici au
centre faites-le l'idée c'est de partir
à la base de la fleur de faire une
première pétales comme ça on va croiser
il plus que je vais grossir plus je vais
éteindre mon mouvement
[Musique]
c'est magnifique
mais là on a l'impression que ces fleurs
le sont vraies mais elle se vend des
semences elles sont faites comment elles
sont faites en sucre
cynthia de son côté décor les gâteaux
que d'autres ont cuisiné autodidacte
elle donne maintenant des formations
ces fleurs là sont faites à base de
secret un peu de blanc 2 on peut
vraiment faire ça chez moi à la maison
peut aussi l'acheter au commerce c'est
comme la pâte à modeler et comment c'est
arrivé
cette union lors entre un gâteau et vos
talents oui donc en fait ça a commencé
avec l'anniversaire de machines et je
voulais lui faire un gâteau juste pour
son anniversaire
sur instagram quand j'ai publié tout le
temps mes oeuvres les gens aimé ça
voulait voir encore plus donc ça m'a
vraiment encouragée souple et à
m'améliorer donc voilà c'est comme ça
que j'ai fait un peu de la nature aussi
sur le gâteau mais quand on est artiste
pourquoi on décide de faire un art aussi
éphémères j'ai toujours cette question
là mais moi je veux aussi immortalisé
ciblé le moment de bonheur le moment de
ces événements-là de mariage tout ça
souhaitez moi bonne chance
et voilà faut se tenir à jour dans une
nouvelle tendance il ya des affaires qui
reste quand même très intemporels comme
le fameux naked key club ça c'est
toujours très tendance y en a qui ont un
style plus rustique avec beacoup de
spatules y en a qui sont plus lisses et
le dans celui là que j'ai fait on ne
commente les de l'ipo parfaitement
lissés
il ya des petites imperfections c'est ce
qu'on recherche également
[Musique]
le vous savez exactement ce que vous
voulez comme résultat non pas du tout
actuellement il n'y a pas de plan de
match on est vraiment dans la création
d'une toile j'ai une idée de placement
couleurs diplômés on sait ce qui arrive
en landau ménard ces clans haut niveau
souvent sous l'inspiration du moment on
dans un thème mexicain pour ce projet là
combien ça peut coûter un gâteau fait
par une artiste le prix d'abord pour
nous c'est de six dollars par portion
pour une finition qui est simple
minimaliste c'est un peu comme la chute
d'une voiture heures on y va avec que ça
paraît qu'un modèle de base besson veut
le toit ouvrant vitré mais il vous
rajoutez une fille frais
combien d'hommes ne peut passer en heure
sur le gâteau qu'on parlera des coteaux
très souvent crème au beurre très
minimaliste que prendre 25 eur puis à
d'autres projets plus élaborés ça peut
prendre 10 15 20 heures les gâteaux
street et j'en ai déjà fait qu'il
pouvait prendre 30 heures de travail ce
que vous pensez autant que ça va prendre
à le manger quand on m a
dit que j par un sport à ceux moins la
satisfaction de la clientèle me de cash
devrait arriver avec le sourire son
compte à ça fait partie de ma pays
[Musique]